chacun ses marques
avec toi
tu as dû être mon temps caressé par
toi tu avais une casquette un et pierre
qui raconte une histoire la différence
la figure du petit poucet s'exprime à
travers et si tu danses un spectacle
conçu par la chorégraphe marion lévy à
destination des tout petits dès 4 ans je
les crée aussi avec l'aide de mariette
navarro qui est aux tris et on a inventé
ensemble cette histoire du petit poucet
et à chaque fois on part d'une
thématique ou d'une figure et puis on
invente notre propre histoire on avait
fait déjà des spectacles jeune public
mais la 4 5 ans c'est aussi un défi et
et là bas en tout cas il m'a ça marche
bien interactif le spectacle permet aux
enfants de participer à l'avancé du
récit en donnant des indications
scéniques
oui
j'ai bien aimé et c'était bien quand on
a fait la galipette et qu il a ramassé
les cailloux du coup ça me fait plaisir
de ne pas aller voir un spectacle aime
bien j'étais bien drôle et quelques
écoles à danser la représentation se
termine avec tous les enfants sur scène
et si tu danses fait partie des six
créations théâtrales du festival odyssée
en yvelines organisée par le théâtre de
sartrouville 13e édition jusqu'au 19
mars c'est la première fois que je
participe à ce festival et c'est une
commande donc du théâtre de sartrouville
c'est vrai que c'est un spectacle tout
terrain puisque en plus le moins jeu
c'est vrai que la contrainte quand ils
m'ont dit le théâtre m'a dit on peut
aller dans des bibliothèques des centres
sociaux des mains théâtre mais pas que
je me suis dit bon je vais partir de
l'a25 de cette contrainte là et si tu
danses ainsi que les cinq autres
créations partent en tournée dès
maintenant dans plus de 50 villes
culturelles yvelinois différents comme
les théâtres les bibliothèques ou encore
les centres sociaux